for me to Canada
every time the Tao shot Tasha well
Americans say Natasha Natasha Natasha
really I like Natasha I like the touch
more is more elegance Natasha is like
you from together always like this
assuming right it was extremely serious
the movie itself is very serious and um
we're all very serious a lot of Tears oh
no it wasn't it was super it was the
best summer of my life it was very camp
like getting into getting into stuff and
Gavin mischief and laughing up stuff and
making lanyards and what did you guys
find out about yourselves that you
didn't know coming out like about each
other I didn't know that Kate could grub
our usual graduated shirt was like say
it I felt my grownups
yes yeah what are you gonna wear them
next it's all about girl power it's so
now it's so relevant cuz everyone's got
the girl squads and and all the girl
bosses and stuff like that so why do you
think there's backlash why do you think
there's some people who can't handle an
all-female lead it's just new and just
go see the movie edge which makes no
sense then it won't be some rights have
been going to it almost 100 years but
yeah yeah I mean it's I think it's just
new right I think it's new just seeing
girls tough
I mean his think about it got Wonder
Woman out
right right I think they're just now
seeing women in a you know masculine
worry not just a pat was powerful being
you know taking charge of the story
right usually they'd look like Angelina
Jolie
you won't her to kick your ass
alright it was you guys believe in
ghosts or have you guys ever had any
kind of experiences with us a spirit
dear yes I've had a couple of expenses
but I think that they're nice goes I
don't think that they're mean I don't
think ghosts of mean I think that nice I
think the main ones go straight today
oblivion I am still waiting for my first
ghost experience and I would appeal to
them right now and say I'm alone in my
hotel room tonight
come let's make did you see that talking
to you and if you could inhabit anyone's
body who would you want to have it well
you know how that goes come into you and
yours laughing okay that have to be one
body though yeah they'd be on a series
of bodies show okay first I will go to
Halle Berry ten minutes just look like I
will walk around and then I would jump
jump right out of her into Michelle
Obama and be like oh yeah and do like
this real quick like you know and then
probably jump in the cake I feel I jump
into Leslie's body just so I could go
like that